[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
so it's clear that high-end mobile
phones are slowly becoming more
expensive over the years but why in this
video we'll take a look at some possible
reasons of why on this channel we've
already covered the fascinating stories
of the very first mobile phone in 1983
and the first smartphone released in
1994 in these videos we saw that the
prices were nine thousand two hundred
dollars and one thousand eight hundred
dollars respectively
so what we're witnessing right now isn't
the first time that smartphones have
been really expensive after the 1990s
however mobile phones did fall in price
around the world as we enjoyed
accessible mobile communication but as
the 2000s rolled around our phones began
to do more than just communicate and
with the extra functionality came higher
prices the prices really started to
climb when fully capacitive touchscreen
smartphones hit the market the original
iPhone in 2007 set the bar at $600 and
since then the prices of subsequent
iPhones and high-end Android devices
have steadily been climbing
[Applause]
he's a chart by Bloomberg of all the
popular smartphone prices over the years
as you can see there's a clear upward
trend but Google's pixel line stands out
as great valley that also begs the
question are the other top brands
overcharging to gain more of a profit
possibly to appear stockholders this may
be partly true but as you'll see in this
video there are other clear reasons as
to why the prices are increasing we'll
be using mostly Samsung and Apple as
examples the Samsung Galaxy Note 8
starts at 930 US Dollars and the iPhone
10 starts at 1,000 u.s. dollars both
record-breaking prices unfortunately
when you include sales tax foreign
exchange rates and trade tariffs the
prices can explode the iPhone is 25%
higher in Australia 30% more expensive
in China 32% more expensive in the UK
and 47% more expensive in Hungary where
the cheapest version of the iPhone 10
costs 1500 u.s. dollars spending that
much money on the lowest configuration
of an iPhone is something that the world
has never seen before so let's dig right
into it here are three reasons for the
increases in price reason number one top
smartphones are costing more to make the
smartphone industry is one of the only
sectors where consumers constantly
expect innovation and new features every
year manufacturers have to overcome
space constraints strive to reduce power
consumption while providing more
features and a better user experience
this all doesn't come for free every new
innovation demands engineering knowledge
testing and calculated design choices a
[Music]
simple measure of the raw cost of a
phone is its Bill of Materials basically
a list of the components and their
prices used to create the device here's
a chart by Android Authority showing the
Bill of Materials for the Galaxy S
series over the years as you can see
there's an upward trend if we look at
the sales prices of the Galaxy S series
is the same deal there's an upward trend
in both of them but in 2017 something
interesting did happen the SI was the
most expensive phone to make by far it
costed an estimated 307 US dollars to
make 43 dollars higher than the s7 and
36 dollars higher than the s7 edge
according to Andrew Russ wheeler of H is
market quote the higher total bill of
materials for the Galaxy sa seems to be
part of a trend that reflects something
of an arms race and features among Apple
Samsung and other phone manufacturers as
they all tried to add new and
distinguishing hardware features end
quote so in essence the weapons of this
arms race are the phone components and
the battle is for your wallet the build
materials for the iPhone 10 is said to
be four hundred and twelve dollars also
by far the most expensive to get the
total cost of manufacturing the phones
you need to add in research and
development needed for testing new
features advertising costs manufacturing
costs administrative costs and a pushed
outdo their competitor all within a one
to two year product's life cycle
taking this into consideration it
becomes easy to see how prices can begin
to creep up reason number two
smartphones are becoming more capable
it's obvious that phones are getting
more powerful today's top smartphones in
some respect have as much grunt as a
laptop from just a few years ago in fact
the Qualcomm Snapdragon 835 chip which
is used in most high-end smartphones by
Samsung HTC LG Sony and Nokia is so
powerful that it's now being used in
full Windows 10 pcs a field normally
dominated by Intel and AMD Asus Lenovo
and HP have all signed up to use the new
mobile chip in their computers this
machine is running Windows 10 on a
Qualcomm Snapdragon processor you can
see this is running 64-bit Windows 10
Enterprise Edition with four gigabytes
of RAM I'll pull up the task manager so
you can see the full power of the
Qualcomm Snapdragon processor with its
four cores in action this is Adobe's
Photoshop running great on a Qualcomm
processor we made zero changes to the
app it runs perfectly I'll select a
radial blur filter on the ninja cat just
to show you that this is real photo shop
with all the functionality you would
expect another tough performance test on
any PC is playing a game here we have
the popular Windows 10 game World of
Tanks blitz as you can see it runs great
super smooth this is pretty remarkable
to see as it shows that the conversions
between the PC and mobile computing is
getting closer than ever before
something that I did talk about in some
of my earliest videos
when these new powerful chips comes
capabilities for features such as
augmented reality and virtual reality
all of this as well as new concepts like
the iPhones neural engine to help with
recognizing speech and images as well as
dual camera setups to allow for more
options during photos and videos all are
incentives for people to pay a higher
price for their mobile device these
extra capabilities feed into the third
reason reason number three supply and
demand at the end of the day it all
comes down to supply and demand as long
as people are willing to pay high prices
for mobile power and all of these new
features the manufacturers can sell them
at these high prices in addition there
are numerous studies that have revealed
that psychological dependence on
smartphones is quite widespread and
within that group there's a segment of
people that always want up-to-date
technology it's just part of their
personality nobody actually has to
upgrade their phones every one or two
years but millions of people do because
of this reason high prices can be
sustained but the question is if
manufacturers keep increasing the price
what is the threshold at which the
customers say no brand perception also
has a part two plan on the demand side
if a person is fond of the Apple or
Samsung brand they're more likely to see
the cost is worth it it's not all bad
though there's a growing number of
alternative options some of the
mid-range phones really aren't that bad
anymore the Chinese brand Huawei now the
world's second largest smartphone
manufacturer can provide much cheaper
alternatives the same goes for Xiaomi
Google's pixel lineup and Oppo further
to this if the goal of your phone is
just to get the job done a two year old
high-end phone is still decent one final
note to take away is that the actual
average price of smart phones is
actually going down across all of the
world except for the United States one
interpretation of this data is that
although the highest models are going up
in price the rest of the market is
getting more efficient at sourcing parts
and the manufacturing process so they're
able to pass those savings on to the
consumer as you've seen the high-end
models are always trying new things and
paving the
and innovation is generally expensive in
conclusion smartphones have definitely
come a long way since 1994 and the
capabilities have just exploded over the
past decade the cost of having the very
best in mobile technology is going up
but when we demand so much from our
devices it's no surprise so what do you
guys think do you agree or disagree with
the reasons listed in this video what's
the price threshold for you when it
comes to buying a new phone anyway
that's it I hope you enjoyed this video
feel free to subscribe to this channel
if you just stumbled across it also I
know that some of you have been asking
if I have any merch for sale and the
answer is now yes but it's only for a
limited run for the next 15 days you'll
be able to get your hands on some cold
fusion clothing in a couple of designs
so if you want to help support the
channel and get some CF threads the
links will be in the description below
this has been - gogo you've been
watching cold fusion and I'll catch you
again soon for the next video cheers
guys have a good one
[Music]